But before I elaborate on any of these answers in our grid, let's remember what
the general formula for slope is. We can find two points along any of these
lines, and then compare them using this formula to find the slope. The first
line, v, is a really interesting case. If we pick any two points along it, let's
say negative 7,3 and negative 3,3. You'll notice that they have the same
y-coordinate, they have the same vertical position. That means that our
numerator of our slope formula is going to be zero, since we'll just have 3
minus 3. Zero divided by any number except zero is just zero. So, the slope of v
is just zero. w is another really interesting case. It's this vertical line
right here. Although, the points along w have a wide variety of y values, they
all have exactly the same x value. x equals negative 5 for any point we could
place along this line. So, let's just pick 2 again. Maybe this point, negative
5,6, and this point negative 5, negative 1. Then, we have negative 1 minus 6
over negative 5 plus 5. But, this quantity on the bottom is going to give us
zero and we know that we can't divide by zero. That is just not allowed, at
least not for right now. So, what we say is that the slope is undefined. Line x
is pointing up to the right, so its slope is positive. And if we step over one
to the right, we have to step up more than one to rejoin our line. So, its slope
is not a fraction. It's greater than one. The line y also has a positive slope.
But, if we pick a point and move over one to the right, we have to move less
than one unit up to rejoin the graph. So, this slope is a fraction. Line z
points down to the right, so as we saw before, its slope is negative.